Dr. Brain is a drama about the
human desire and curiosity
in wanting to look into
other people's brains.
We've all been curious
about what other
people are thinking and feeling.
This primal curiosity
has now evolved,
into the synchronization
using quantum entanglement.
Maybe it's a dream like feeling
and you can't remember it.
That's the kind of
approach I took.
As is the case with
many actors in Korea,
working with director
Kim Jee-Woon,
especially for people around my
age, I have loved his work since
I was in my twenties.
I grew up watching those works,
and since he is a director I
respect so much, I think it was
an honor to just work with him.
I think all productions
are very similar to the
director who directs them.
But especially for this
show, Go Sewon seems
a bit similar to the director.
A little blunt,
but very deep...
Sewon, we're all going out for
- I'll pass
I've seen many of
director Kim's work
and I also like many
of them as well.
While working with
him, I was surprised
by the degree of detail
and sensitivity he had.
I realized that his
great works were
a result of that part of him,
that was great fun.
Also, because he's
familiar with science
fictions mysteries
and family movies.
I think the director
is very for this kind
of work where complex
genres are mixed.
I think the director is very
optimized for this kind of work.
I think the director's
thoughts, feeling, colors
and smells exist
in every scence.
From the artwork,clothing,
props, hair, and makeup
he looks at every detail
of character or the setting
with great detail, so it will be
an unforgettable experience.